[موسيقى]
تستطيعون ان تكسروا كل الباطون على رؤوسهم
لكن رؤوسهم لا تنكسر فهي مصممه ومصممه على
رفض الركوع لغير الله تستطيعون قتلهم عن
بعد لكنهم صابرون المبشرون المتنافسون بين
سابقين ولاحق دفاعا عن الوجود والرسوخ
والعدل والدين والحق بوطن لا يحرق ولا
يغرق لانه وطن حلال قد يسرق الى حين لكن
مصير اللصوص خلف القضبان تلك هي سنه
التاريخ التي لن تتبدل في فلسطين وائل
الدحدوح ابا حمزه الشهيد بل ابى الشهداء
سامحنا حيلتنا صف الحروف ودربك لا يدرك
بالكلمات يا جبل غزه معليش لن نغفر لهم
فانهم يعلمون ما يفعلون تكتب فتاه
فلسطينيه الى
[موسيقى]
العناوين الدحدوح يودع روح الروح حمزه
الذي التحق بامه واخوته
الشهداء نتنياهو يريد اخضاع مساعديه
الكذابين الى اختبار كشف
الحقيقه مسؤولون اسرائيليون يطالبون
بتنفيذ الواجب الديني باباده اهل
غزه جنرال اسرائيلي سابق لا تعتقد ان
الفلسطينيين سيستسلم
يوصفون بمرتزقة
في جيش
الاحتلال متصهين عربيه تختصر الطريق وتنسق
مباشره مع المساد والعسكر ايهود براك
ومحامي اسرائيل في لهاي غارقان في جزيره
الاغتصاب مرحبا ماذا بين اسرائيل ووائل
الدحدوح مدير مكتب قناه الجزيره في غزه من
كتب الفاتوره نتنياهو ام بن كفير ام
جنرالات الموت في تل ابيب كل التكنولوجيا
العسكريه
والتجسس البالغه الدقه التي بين ايديهم
تجعل من المستحيل ان نصدق بانهم قصفوا
منزل وائل بالصدفه وقتلوا ام حمزه وبعض
الابناء وانه مستهدف بعد ذلك بالخطا وائل
ضمن تجمع للصحفيين يتعقب المساد هواتفهم
وتواجدهم كل لحظه فاستشهد الزميل سامر ابو
دقه وجرح ابو حمزه ثم قتلوا اخيرا حمزه
وزميله الصحفي مصطفى ثريه وائل يهزم طائر
الفينيق الذي يقوم من بين الرماد فيحلق
عاليا في سماء الصبر والثبات والاحتساب
عند الله ارحم الراحمين عزاءه ليس برقيات
من بيت ابيض او بيوت اخرى داعمه لاسرائيل
بل عزاؤه ان الواجب الانساني يباركه الله
صحيح ان الالم كبير جدا والوجع اكبر
والثمن باهر جدا جدا جدا فحمى يعني كان
كلي وليس بضعه مني كان نفسي وروحي وجاء
بعد ان خسرت زوجتي وشقيق محمود هشام وادم
واقاربي زميلي سامر لكن بالتاكيد هذا
الثمن وهذا الوجع لن يثنينا عن مواصله
الطريق
اكيد هذا امر صعب وليس سهل ولكن كما قلنا
لن نتردد ولو للحظه واحده ولن نتوقف للحظه
واحده طالما اننا على قيد الحلا الحياه
وطالما اننا قادرون على اداء هذا الواجب
فنحن سنقوم بذلك كدون تردد فهي رساله
انسانيه نبيله مقدسه كفلتها كل القوانين
والمواثيق الدوليه
والانسانيه ولذلك نحن ماضون وايضا لان من
استشهدوا وسفح دمائهم ابتداء من حمزه وامه
واخيه وشام ضحوا بكثير باعز ما يملكون حتى
استمر انا على هذا الطريق وبالتالي كان
لزاما علي ان اكون وفيا بالحد الادنى
واستمر بارك الله فيكم نتنياهو يطالب
باخضاع كبار المسؤولين في تل ابيب لاختبار
كشف الكذب من اجل ضمان عدم تسريب محادثات
الاجتماعات الى الاعلام خطوه منطقيه جدا
بسبب سوء الامانه المستشري في ربعهم لكن
هل يبدا نتنياهو باجراء اختبار الكذب على
نفسه بحسب صحيفه تلغراف البريطانيه اقترح
نتنياهو تطبيق هذا الاجراء على كل
المسؤولين الذين يحضرون المناقشات الحساسه
التي تتعلق بتفاصيل الحرب في اسرائيل
يقامر القاده السياسيون بحياه الجنود من
اجل مكاسب شخصيه تشكل الاسباب الحقيقيه
لخلافات
المتعاظم تحسبهم حكومه واحده لكن قلوبهم
شتى
مع بدايه الشهر الرابع للحرب على غزه وصلت
الخلافات الداخليه السياسيه والعسكريه في
تلبيب حد التشظي لم يعد يخفى الان على احد
بان ما يجري في تل ابيب هو توظيف سياسي
للحرب غير مرتبط بمجرى العمليات العسكريه
داخل قطاع غزه انما يرتبط بمستقبل بعض
الشخصيات السياسيه والاحزاب وما تؤول
اليها الامور من اعاده النخ السياسيه
لاحقا اكاديميه اسرائيليه متعصبه لنتنياهو
تدعو الى هزيمه حماس بدل اقاله نتنياهو
يعني هي تكذب اعلامهم الذي يدعي هزيمه
المقاومه الاكاديميه المتطرفه تقول بالعبر
نحن لو شخ خيم
نحن
باخ
ي جلين استغرب مطالبه اسرائيل بوقف اباده
الفلسطينيين واستشهد بتاريخ امريكا مع
اليابان وتشرشل مع
الالمان ملين بس
بهس
المتشوق لالقاء قنبله نوويه على غزه امي
خاي الياهو وزير التراث الاسرائيلي الصادق
في التعبير عن تراث اسرائيل طالب بالبحث
عن طرق اكثر ايلاما من الموت للانتقام من
الفلسطينيين والنائب موشيه سعده في وصله
روحانيه يؤكد ان الاباده واجبه
دينيا دافن ولا مش دافن
يش الاحتلال يفجر مسجدا في خان يونس
ويسويه بالارض مكررا اكاذيبه بان المسجد
كان مركزا لخرب وتحته نفق دون ان يقدم اي
صوره تدعم افتراه على بيوت
اللهخ
لو
[موسيقى]
ز 2 اح
رشي
اليس في اسرائيل من يقرا التاريخ هل
يعتقدون ان الامور لن تتبدل هل دامت
لغيرهم حتى تدوم لهم الزعيم الدرزي
اللبناني وليد جون بلاط سبق ان نصح بوطنيه
وحكمه الجنود الدروز في جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي بعدم محاربه المقاومه
الفلسطينيه فسياتي اليوم الذي تعود فيه
فلسطين
ومقدساتها الى
اصحابها الطائرات الامريكيه لم تتسع
لعملائها في افغانستان اثناء الانسحاب وجه
الزعيم الدرزي وليد جلاط في منشور لافت
عبر منصه اكس رساله الى من سماهم المجندين
قهرا من العرب الدروس في الجيش الاسرائيلي
قائلا لهم اياكم الاشتراك في الحرب في
مواجهت المناضلين من حماس ومن الشعب
الفلسطيني ان حركه التاريخ مهما طالت مع
حريه الشعوب وسياتي اليوم التي ستعود
فلسطين ومقدساتها الى اصحابها العرب يذكر
ان الدروز يشغلون في الجيش الاسرائيلي
دورا اثار تساؤلات على مر الزمن حيث بلغت
حتى العام 2022 نسبه الدروز الذين يؤدون
الخدمه العسكريه في الجيش الاسرائيلي
85% وفق الجزيره التي لفتت الى ان هذه
النسبه تفوق نسبه اليهود المنخرطين في
صفوف الجيش تتوالى اعترافات جنود الاحتلال
بقتلهم الاطفال الفلسطينيين
والمفارقه ان معظم القتله من النساء وحشه
بشريه تتباهى بقتلها خمسه
اطفال
اذا كانت اسرائيل تبحث عن ارقام قياسيه
لنفسها على لائحه جينس فقد اصبح بامكانها
ان تقول انا الاكثر تدميرا في التاريخ
الحديث تكشف صحف امريكيه ويؤكد علماء
غربيون ان اثار الدمار الذي خلفه العدوان
الاسرائيلي على غزه يماثل اكثر الحملات
تدميرا في التاريخ الحديث اسرائيل تريد
تهجير الفلسطينيين الى الكونجو
والفلسطينيون بيقولوا للكونجو اذهب نحن
باقون في فلسطين ولا نستبدلها الا بفلسطين
اذ كشف تقرير لصحيفه تايمز في اسرائيل عن
معطيات صادمه حول محادثات سريه تجريها
الحكومه اسرائيليه لاستقبال الفلسطينيين
فيما يسمى بالهجره الطوعيه وقالت الصحيفه
ان الحكومه اجرت اتصالات مع الكونجو ودول
اخرى للوصول الى اتفاق ترحيل الفلسطينيين
بعد القضاء على حركه حماس نوجا اربيل
محلله
استراتيجيه اسرائيليه منشغل بالها بارحم
الفلسطينيات تريد منعهن من الولاده فتدعو
الى تدمير وكاله الا
فلانه تعتقد ان الفلسط يتكاثرون بواسطه
الاون هم يتزوجون حتى في النزوح لان من
احب فتاه ي عده لها ويتزوجها كيف ما كانت
الظروف هم لا يكذبون على بنات الناس
عروستنا احل من الجمر بشويه عروستنا احل
من القمر بشويه ليس التكاثر مفيدا اذا كان
على جهل وبلا قيم وروح غزه لم تنسى صغيرات
امهات المستقبل حتى في النزوح فمراكز
تحفيظ القران الكريم استحدثت تحت الخيام
اعوذ بالله من الشيطان
الرجيم بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم بسم الله
الرحمن الرحيم نازحه في مدرسه اجينا على
المخيم وعملوا لنا خيمه عشان نحفظ القران
فصرنا نحفظ القران قبل في المدارس كنا
نحفظ قران بالمساجد بس هقيتها خلص عشان
صرنا نازحين عملوا لنا خيمه وصرنا نحفظ
قران اذا اعتقد شخص ان الفلسطينيين
سيستسلم
فهو لا يعرفهم نصيحه يقدمها رئيس جهاز
الشباك الاسبق عامي ايالون لمن يهمه الامر
شو بتعملي
اغراض ليش وين بدك تروحي فلين وين
فلسطين طب عند مين بدك تروحي عند ابو
عبيده ليش بدك تعملي يا ماما اهد بسبيل
الله ناجح فلسطين في المقابل جنود
اسرائيليون يغنون بفرح هستيري وكانهم
ولدوا من جديد بعد تسريحهم من معارك الحرب
على
غزه طلال ابو غزاله
يطمنكم نحن الان على بعد شراره من الحرب
العالميه الثالثه لكن نهايه اسرائيل بدات
يقول قادم افضل ام اسوا قادم طبعا افضل
افضل ولكن ايمتى بده يصير هذا القادم
نتيجه حرب والحرب بدات ا من يوم احتلال
اوكرانيا او الهجوم على اوكرانيا نن الحرب
نحن فيها اه ولكن منتظرين الاحتكاك
العسكري المباشر بين الصين وامريكا وسيحدث
ذلك وسيحدث ذلك وقريبا لماذا توقعك عن حرب
غزه بدايه حرب التحرير انهاء الاحتلال
التغير التاريخي اللي حصل صل والفضل فيه
للاحتلال انه حول المقاومه الى شعب يعني
انا بتمنى انه اللي بده يكذبني يعطيني
واحد من غزه بقول انا ضد
[موسيقى]
حماس كل ظالم طرك غزه تعاني كل ظالم اتخلى
عن غزه وتامر على غزه اخرتك هان ويحطوا
عليك البلاط وتضلك لح حالك
هيسالوك عن الاطفال اللي سبتهم يموتوا بدم
بارد هيسالوك عن النساء يسالوك عن الشيوخ
يسالوك عن الشباب اخرتكم هان وحين سكر
عليكم وتصير عتمه وكلكم زلام حاسبوا على
الفاتوره تحت واهل غزه حيكونوا خصمكم يوم
القيامه باذن الله
سكر نهايه الظلمه هنا هنا هنا هنا للذين
صموا اذانهم عن مذبحه العصر في غزه هذه
رساله بلغه الاشاره واللبيب من الاشاره
يفهم اذا
[موسيقى]
بد مرتزقه ماكرون هكذا باتوا يوصفون انهم
دواف فرنسا في جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
ينشدون المرس ياز النشيد الوطني الفرنسي
على الجبهه وقيم الجمهوريه الفرنسيه تبكي
خلف المتاريس
استرالي وبريطاني التحقا بجيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وتحدثا للكاميرات فهل تكون
التسجيلات كافيه لتحقق معهما الحكومتان
الاست يه والبريطانيه على الاقل بتهمه
ارتكاب جرائم حرب ضد
المدنيين ميعه بريطانيه متحمسه لاسرائيل
اكثر من جولدا مائير بعز شباب تمارس قمعا
خشنا على السياسي الفلسطيني الخلوق
والدبلوماسي مصطفى
البرغوثي المذيعه اتهمته بانه ليس متعودا
على مقابله امراه علما ان بهيج مازال حتى
الان يبحث عن المراه في المقابله ساعدوه
اذا
فيكم
روان سوريه من ام لبنانيه لا يعترف بها
لبنان وتبرا منها سوريا جمعت الخيانه من
اطرافها فذهبت من اوروبا الى تل ابيب
لتوسط الناطقين العسكريين اسرائيليين
وتتهم المقاومه
الفلسطينيه بالارهاب روان تدعي بانها
صحفيه فما علاقتها بالمسد وبجي الاحتلال
لتلتقي ممثلين عنه اليوم بدي اعرفكم على
امراه لبنانيه سوريه من محبي السلام اجت
لحتى تتضامن معنا نحن الاسرائيليه ولحتى
تقول بصوت عالي انه دواعش حماس ما يمثلوني
لذلك نتشرف روان بوجودك معنا اليوم ومعنا
هنا في اسرائيل
شكرا نورت اسرائيل بوجودك معنا الفنان
الايرلندي سي واتكنز يحكي قصه فلسطين
باغنيه عله ينوب عن كتائب مغني الاعراس
العرب في رفع صوت
[موسيقى]
المظلومين
كشف المستور عن جزيره الملذات وصاحبها
المهوس بالقاصرات
الملياردير الامريكي جيفري ابستن المتهم
بارتكاب جرائم جنسيه كالتجار بالجنس مع
قاصرات وثائق تضم الاف الصفحات كشفت عن
الرئيس الامريكي الاسبق كلينتون والسابق
ترامب والامير البريطاني اندرو وغيرهم من
الاسماء ضمن 170 اخرين رفعت المحكمه
الفيدراليه في نيويورك السريه عنها جيفري
ابستن الملياردير الذي انتحر في سجنه عام
2019 قبل محاكمته بجرائم جنسيه حتى ان
المشاهير والنجوم والفنانين وكبار الساسه
كانوا ضيوفا شبه دائمين على موائده
العامره التي يقيمها كان ينقل ابستن
القاصرات الى الجزيره الى جزيره لاتل سانت
جيمس احدى جزر الكاريبي التي كان يمتلكها
ابستن وبنى عليها قصرا يتردد عليه
الاصدقاء اسرائيل حاضره على مستوى رفيع في
فضائح وثيقه جزيره اغتصاب القاصرات ايهود
براك كان ضيفا دائما على ابستين وفق
الاعلام الاوروبي لكن ورود اسمه على
اللائحه الامريكيه فيه تاكيد ومن ابرز
الاسماء رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي الاسبق
ايهود باراك الذي وفقا للوثائق كان يتردد
بانتظام على ابستين وطو اربع سنوات محامي
اسرائيل امام محكمه العدل الدوليه متورط
حتى النخاع بحسب وثائق ابستين لكنه طالب
بادانه حماس بدلا منه هنا يعلق خليل
الفلسطيني حماس ليست متهمه باغتصابك عزيزي
انت المتهم باغتصاب
القصر انا لم ارتكب اي خطا لكنني احذر من
تقاعس المجموعات الرا الدكاليه التي صمتت
امام اعتداءات حماس ان نفاق تلك التجمعات
بشان كل ما هو يهودي مقلق حقا لو سالت
هؤلاء المغتصبين المخملين عن تزويج الفتاه
قانونيا دون سن الثامنه ع لقلب الدنيا
عليك لماذا ينقدون شرعنا في قضيه اجازه
زواج الصغيره
القاصره وقوانينهم تسمح في بلدانهم
بالعلاقه غير الشرعيه في المدارس بين
القاصرات وبين وكثير من السفاح والحمل حدث
فيه ليست القضيه مجرد والعياذ بالله انها
هتكت عذرتها ومارست الحرام والعلاقه
الجنسيه المحرمه وص لا يرون انه حراما
مادام بالتراضي وصلت الى حد الحمل تحمل
وهي لا تزال عمرها ع سنين والحمل يضر بها
وانا معي دراسه من تقريبا اثن عش صفحه حول
الاضرار الصحيه المترتبه على زواج
الصغيرات هذا في الزواج المباح بزوج يخاف
الله عز وجل ومرضي الدين والخل
قد يكون في اضرار عليها خاصه اذا حملت
مبكرا فكيف بطفله يعاشرها ربما في اليوم
الواحد عده ذئب من هؤلاء الفجره المجرمين
لقد اوتيت السلطات الامريكيه من الفراسه
ما يجعلها تؤكد ان جريمه قتل الشيخ حسن
شريف امام جامع امريكي في نيو جرسي ليست
بدافع كراهيه الاسلام لكنها لا تعرف عن
الجريمه اي شيء اخر
مقتل الشيخ حسن شريف امام مسجد محمد نيو
ارك بولايه نيو جيرسي الامريكيه ووفقا
لوسائل اعلام امريكيه فان الشيخ حسن خرج
من المسجد يوم الاربعاء بعد صلاه الفجر
وتعرض لاطلاق النار من شخص مجهول لاذا
بالفرار تم نقل الشيخ الى المستشفى وتوفي
متاثرا باصابته والى الان لم تتوصل الشرطه
الامريكيه الى الجاني او دوافع واسباب هذا
الاغتيال الاثيم خلال تدشين الحملات
الانتخابيه الرئاسيه بايدن يتهم ترامب
بانه يستخدم اسلوب النازيين فيرد ترامب
بان بايدن محاط بالفاش
والشيوعيين انتم ماذا تقولون هل بايدن محق
ام ترامب ام ان كليهما
صادقان
اخيرا لقد حكم موقع يوتيوب على الحلقه
السابقه من فوق السلطه
370 بما يشبه الاعدام عندما قيد الوصول
اليها بحجه تضمنها مشاهد لضحايا غزه
يعتبرها الموقع مؤديه للبعض علما انه
لطالما اتهمت وسائل اعلام وناشطون موقع
يوتيوب بترويج الدعايه التي تصور اسرائيل
باعتبارها ضحيه بكل الاحوال اذا تحولت بعض
منصات التواصل الى دكتاتوريه فان التحول
عنها سيكون حتميا
وللجميع
[موسيقى]
هجم اسد على وادي الحمير فهربت جميعها
باستثناء واحد منها اقعده الخوف عن الهروب
فتراجع الاسد امامه ليصدق حمارنا نفسه
بانه يخيف الاسود لحقه الى الغابه يطارده
بين اشجارها والاس د يواصل التراجع الى
لحظه وجد فيها الحمار نفسه واقعا في كمين
لره ط من الاسود يتحلقون على مائده الغداء
وليس عليها فريسه وقف الحمار ونه قائلا
اعلم اني ميت لكن عندي سؤال للاسد الجبان
الذي كنت اطارده لماذا لم يواجهني ضحك
الاسد وقال له لقد راهنت رفاقي على لانني
ساصل لهم الطعام طازجا الى
مائدتهم رد الحمار اذا يذبحوني فانا الذي
لوث سمعه قومه ولم يهرب كباقي
الحمير لقطه الختام كمائن القسام لجنود
الاحتلال وجديدها في حي الزيتون الى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء
m
الله اكبر وله
الحمد تفجير تفجير القوه جنود الص
الخنازير
بالقرب في حي
[موسيقى]
الزيتون
ا